Lebanon has one of the most complex
political systems in the world the tiny
country is made up of 18 different sects
and his political system is designed to
give nearly all of them to say since
Lebanon's independence the country's
leadership positions have been divided
between the three main sects
Lebanon's President must be a Maronite
Christian the Prime Minister of Sunni
and the Speaker of the House a Shia
seats in parliament are also based on
sectarian proportioning with each sect
receiving a set number of seats in the
political body Lebanese citizens can
only vote for candidates from the
specific sects that are designated for
their district this sort of system often
leads to a political stalemate and
sometimes even violence so is there a
better political system for Lebanon